un bras de fer sans fin entre la chine
et les états unis et la crise du
coronavirus accentue un peu plus chaque
jour ce rapport de force
donald trump vient même de déclarer
qu'il n'excluait pas de rompre toutes
relations avec la chine
après avoir longtemps qualifié le
coville 19 de virus chinois il a
surenchéri il ya quelques jours en
parlant cette fois ci je cite de la
peste de chine
comme je le répète depuis longtemps
traitée avec la chine est très onéreux
nous venions tout juste d'acter un
gigantesque accord commercial lancre
était quasiment sèche que le monde a été
frappée par la piste chinoise
une façon toute personnelle pour le
locataire de la maison blanche de
souligner la responsabilité de pékin
dans la propagation de l'épidémie
depuis des mois l'administration trump
accusent les autorités chinoises d'avoir
tardé à alerter le monde sur l'épidémie
est d'en avoir même dissimulé l'ampleur
pire le président américain et le
secrétaire d'état michael p ô accuse
ouvertement pékin d'avoir dissimulé un
accident dans un laboratoire de one qui
serait selon eux à l'origine de la
pandémie
n'oubliez pas que ce n'est pas la
première fois que la chine infecte le
monde et qu'elle a l'habitude de gérer
des laboratoires ne respectant pas les
normes
ce n'est pas la première fois que nous
avons un monde exposé à des virus qui
résultent de défaillance d'un
laboratoire chinois
si le discours se durcit les décisions
se font elles aussi de plus en plus
musclé à l'égard de la chine
donald trump multiplie ainsi les mesures
de rétorsion à l'égard du géant
asiatique
dernière en date l'interdiction pour le
système de retraites des fonctionnaires
américains de procéder à l'achat de
titres financiers chinois
désormais c'est sur le plan de
l'espionnage industriel que
l'administration américaine s'en prend à
pékin le fbi et l'agencé américaine de
cybersécurité accuse des pirates
informatiques soi-disant affiliés à la
chine de cibler des organisations
américaines chargées de la recherche sur
le comique 19
ces acteurs ont été surpris en train de
tenter d'identifier et d'acquérir
illégalement auprès de réseaux et
d'individus impliqués dans la recherche
contre le kobe 19 des données liées aux
vaccins aux traitements et aux tests
le vol potentiel de ces informations
menace la mise à disposition d'options
de traitement sûr et efficace
de son côté pékin dénonce des calories
la chine exprime son vif mécontentement
et sa ferme opposition à une telle
diffamation de la part des états unis
à en juger par les antécédents les
etats-unis ont mené les plus grandes
opérations de cyber vols dans le monde
la chine a réalisé des avancées
stratégiques importants dans sa lutte
contre l'épidémie ducobu 19
elle a également été en tête du monde en
matière de recherche et de traitement du
vaccin contre le kobe 19
par conséquent la chine a plus de raison
que d'autres de s'inquiéter du
cyberespionnage il se trouve un commis
au lieu d'un jean d'un boîtier mais pour
le professeur où elle ces attaques
américaines sont avant tout une
tentative pour faire oublier une gestion
catastrophique de l'épidémie mais à ce
jour aux états unis plus de 80000
personnes sont mortes et bientôt il y
aura davantage de morts des questions
mais c'est la vérité
ils n'ont pas réussi à protéger leur
peuple et veulent rejeter cette
responsabilité il faut donc de la chine
leur bouc émissaire mais à moins de six
mois de la présidentielle américaine
donald trump est très critiqué pour sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire et le
président américain n'a sans doute rien
contre le fait que les électeurs
puissent reporter leur colère contre la
chine mais prolonger l'épreuve de force
avec l' empire du milieu pourrait avoir
des conséquences sur l'économie
américaine
autre élément qui pèsera certainement
lors du scrutin du 3 novembre